Oh Hank has been an incredibly intense
and overwhelming week in my life with
lots and lots and lots and lots and lots
of interviews which I am NOT good at but
fortunately I've usually been with net
wolf who makes everything in my life
better and also I got to meet many
thousands of nerdfighters around the
country more people wanted to say hello
to you by the way hold on also I got my
photograph taken a lot there's this
whole commodification of the self
involved in this marketing business but
I don't really understand and haven't
processed yet but hopefully I'll make a
video about it someday in the meantime
all I know is that the fancy New York
premiere Paper Towns is tonight by the
way thanks everybody on Twitter and
snapchat helped me pick out my fancy
premiere suit I may need your help later
in choosing a tie by the way the movie
comes out on Friday July 24th but on
Thursday which is the day after freaking
tomorrow there's a special screening and
a bunch of theaters around the u.s. in
Canada I know some of them are sold out
but some of them aren't so hopefully you
can still get a night on the towns come
and get tickets and then in addition to
seeing the movie before everyone else
you will also see a livestream with the
entire cast and musical performances is
going to be really fun also that watch
stream is going to be hosted by our
friend Tyler Oakley who I've known for
like eight years and I'm just so proud
of him and so excited that we get to
celebrate this together Oh Hank you
might be able to tell that I'm a little
bit wound up right now one of the ways
I'm coping with my stress is by reading
reviews of Paper Towns because I just
really really want people to see it and
find out what they think of it and I
just realized that when I heard that
people on Thursday would be the first
people to see the movie I was in fact
lined because the movie is already out
in Brazil and Australia in a couple
other places in like lots of critics
have seen it and fortunately the reviews
have been great like Variety said that
it was better than The Fault in Our
Stars
speaking of which Hank when I was on
tour of exactly zero interviewers said
the title of The Fault in Our Stars
correctly it would be like do you feel a
lot of pressure after all the success of
no fault under these stars and I would
be like well I felt more pressure before
I realize that absolutely no one
remembers the title of that movie right
but anyway I've been obsessively reading
reviews including reviews from Brazil
but unfortunately I do not speak
Portuguese so I've been reading them by
Google Translate and they are very
positive
I think distinguished representative of
the school John Hughes movie paper
cities has everything to be the teen
movie of the year
the result is a fresh and full length
humor far from the melodrama of blame it
star solid
Google Translate blame its star anyway
comparisons John years are always
welcome here's another one it is a
beautiful film the Schreyer I believe
that's director Jake Schreier although
it could be from The Hobbit works with
actors wolf and face not sure who faces
maybe Cara maybe justice is magnificent
in the reunion of the two the dialogue
is as accurate and interpretive and
sincere paper cities that borders on
perfection here's another one heck I'm
moving away from the book literally the
film crew approached the writer in its
essence it's so exploited rites of
passage to adulthood without the
mischievousness of John Hughes but with
The Melancholy of Walt Whitman so yeah
no comparison to John Hughes there but
but it's that Whitman also welcomed
somewhere in the grass underneath our
boot soles Walt Whitman is like yeah I
mean I thought the movie was okay but
let's not get ahead of ourselves anyway
hey I hope that you like the movie in
that nerdfighteria likes it and thanks
to everyone who has shared this journey
with me
one last thing something I've learned
about movie studios in the last two
years is that they're obsessed with
hashtags they're obsesses them because
it allows them to like track the success
of a campaign and I'm sure there will be
lots of super official hashtags around
the Paper Towns movie but I mostly care
about the responses from nerdfighteria
and people who really care about the
story so I thought that I would invent a
fake hashtag and then I can look at that
hashtag instead of like the official
ones don't tell the studio but there's a
Lincoln to do with your nerdfighters I
hope that you like the movie Hank I will
see you on Friday
PS I am so sorry about your VidCon dress
I hope you might find some comfort in
these images of Pluto a cold distant
former planet that humans have come
together to better understand